hello there it's time for a new season
of fortnite Battle Royale a big old hole
has opened up and changed the island
forever and it's packed with tons of
Secrets Mysteries and story updates I'm
Adam Mario here is my code please be
sure to have someone to create a code in
before buying the battle pass anyway
let's do this chapter 4 season 3 Wilds
a mahusive crater has opened up
replacing parts of the Farmland the
woodlands and the winter biome with a
sunken ancient civilization to explore
and instantly fortnite's new story
Direction hits Us in the face as we find
this IO campsite this is now the home of
the never aging imagined order agent
Sloan the reports of her death are
greatly exaggerated Story Time back in
Chapter 3 The imagined order LED on the
field by Sloan were set to use the
collider to eliminate all life on the
island to counter this the seven
recalled Paradigm to the team and
resprayed the giant Mech and fought back
after the collider fell into the ground
we had one final boss battle with Sloan
and her tank until this happened
Last Words Jones
look out
Sloan was yated out of existence looking
closely enough you'll see that Sloane is
able to close the tank exit and somehow
she landed in this new but very old
place and scattered around the island
are audio recordings of the things she's
found I think you know that it takes a
little more than dropping a tank on me
to take me out
I have a plan but I'll need to move fast
key for all of this is the people who
left this jungle behind
Sloan has already spotted us and is
keeping tags on us all but what is she
really looking for this season is all
about the secrets of that crater
surprisingly Sloane is a passive NPC
unless fired upon first it's almost like
she's given up on the imagined order for
something bigger a power never seen
before we'll talk more about that in a
dedicated Story video
down here in the jungle biome another
location can be found that doesn't quite
fit the time period a crash to plane has
become a village showing us that at
least three modern day Expeditions have
found this long-lost civilization Sloan
and her tank The Village plane site and
now to these guys a military-grade
company a highly funded group searching
for artifacts of this new jungle biome
the level of detail in their home base
is really impressive with a dedicated
mechanics garage Fuel Depot and
high-tech surveillance and do you
recognize that logo it's the same one we
saw on the tents at the end of last
season as the earthquakes hit the island
the main focus of this new biome are the
ancient tombs scattered throughout
temples and crypts everywhere some
demand offerings to obtain their secrets
within while the main Temple holds the
sign of the Autobots just like the
trailer told us a few days ago it's a
real location in game so I thought I'd
jump into replay mode to look what's
inside that Vault and yeah there's
nothing at all well at least not yet
this Temple has already been found and
look it's that symbol again those guys
are absolutely everywhere but if there
is so many of them where are they now
why have they vanished something
sinister is going on if you're wondering
how important Optimus Prime is to the
story of fortnite take time to sit in a
vehicle and listen to the radio and
eventually you'll hear Prime attempting
to talk to you greetings
my name is Optimus Prime
if you are hearing this message the time
has come to make your escape this
reality is doomed
to quote what hope is not yet lost
I cannot sustain this broadcast for much
longer listen and more will follow
just like Galactus and the Avengers the
Transformers are going to be officially
in fortnite lore looks like we're saving
reality again hopefully the Decepticons
will try and take over this place but
anyway Optimus is coming I am coming
the next thing I knew I had to find this
season was the zero point at the start
of the chapter it was sealed away
underground we guessed it was in this
very zero point looking vault as it made
certain sounds to confirm that yet now
it's totally gone replaced with this
Monument instead and inside lies a
crystal tier which can be picked up in
game searching slightly more Inland it's
possible to find this orb I don't know
about you but that looks very much like
a zero point to me or at least a
representation of it we know that these
guys like statues so this really could
just be a stone replica of the real
thing yes if we get close enough and
tell our Squad to shut their faces for a
moment this thing May zero point sounds
it's like a gurning whale could this
actually be the Petrified remains of the
zero point meaning the story this season
could be about who will awaken it and
claim its power as their own I mean
we've had a season dedicated to the
origins of the imagined order and the
Ageless so why not make this season
about the zero point and I get the
feeling that agent Sloan has turned her
back on the i o and instead pursues
power for herself
oh this is interesting whilst in replay
mode it's possible to find multiple
Autobot points these aren't live on the
map yet or at least for me they aren't
so likely this is a sneak peek at next
week's activities or maybe the next
update what I was actually doing here
was looking for movement around the map
fortnite has a tendency of putting
vehicles in a line to show you the
direction of the next update coming next
time around and they've done it again
this time it's possible to find convoys
four or five vehicles deep moving around
the island expanding their home base
this Convoy in particular uses a reboot
van to tow Goods around by following the
road it appears they are visiting the
temple next to the zero point next which
means the next update should continue
the storyline away from the hole the map
changes continue such as at some of the
old medieval turret style castles under
a few of them are now a vault with a
wild car character and henchmen moving
around to protect them and like always
the Vault cards reveal a ton of Loot and
gold for you and your squad a map change
I was not expecting comes about where
those monoliths are we had three at the
end of last season yet two of those big
buggers have now gone vanished forever
their importance may never be known I
double checked the original is still
there and it is and it's happy and it's
still indestructible but where did
number two and three go is this an epic
error or they just decided to take the
storyline another Direction the new
jungle biome has ripped apart many pois
to take their place the Frozen makeshift
Igloo that the Tilted Towers clock found
itself in has been smashed to Pieces but
somehow that structure completely
refuses to stay down it now stands proud
Frozen above the jungle biome it's still
missing a few sections from that time we
had a scrap with AIO but this tilted
Towers icon cannot be destroyed
reading notes be sure to read them
before you steal them by the way and
that will unveil an ancient Relic once
owned by Aurelia herself the queen of
gold we haven't seen her since Lara
Croft visited the game when she was tomb
raiding this season seems to be like a
game of Tomb Raider or Uncharted as the
modern day lore is entwined with
mythical deities from a Time forgotten
fortnite is evolving this season looks
like a good one I'm Adam you're awesome
I'll see you next time oh yo and this is
the umbrella for winning one and only
win for the season is done see ya